[Police Sirens Blaring]
- [Mark] Alright Kevin,
Kevin where'd you grow up.
- I grew up in Inglewood, California.
- [Mark] Inglewood, okay.
And how long have you been
out on the street now?
- Uh I've been out a year, but I violated,
so right now I've been out eight years
cause I went back to jail.
- [Mark] But since your last prison term
you've been out just a few months right?
- Uh yeah. Eight... Going on eight months.
- [Mark] Eight months yeah?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And what were you in prison for?
- Torture, aggravated mayhem.
- [Mark] Torture.
- Aggravated mayhem.
- [Mark] Mayhem?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's what they call it?
- Torture and aggravated mayhem.
- [Mark] Wow.
- Yes.
- [Mark] And how many
years did you get for that?
- I did 22 years.
I got a life sentence
when I was 15 years old
for that crime.
- [Mark] A life sentence at 15?
- Yes. At 15.
They charged me as an adult, bound me
over to adult court and I
lost my trial was found guilty
for my charges and was sentenced
to what they call an
indeterminate life sentence
which was seven years to life.
But I did 22 years on my life sentence.
- [Mark] What were the
circumstances that got you?
I mean, what was the...
what was the offense?
It wasn't murder.
- No, I wasn't in jail for murder.
I went to jail for
torture, aggravated mayhem.
In 1996 I was convicted
for uh, burning uh...
Someone... for uh,
for some gang... you know.
Personal things that I, you
know, I, I needed to do.
I don't want to get into detail about that
but I got convicted for torturing someone
for burning them with
hot spoons over his body.
And uh, I did 22 years for it.
- [Mark] And you were in a gang?
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Which gang were you in?
- I was part of the neighborhood Pirus.
In Inglewood California.
- [Mark] Which is part of the Bloods?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And so that means
you didn't go to high school.
- Did I go to high school?
I dropped out of school after elementary.
- [Mark] Oh you did?
- Yes.
- [Mark] So that was even
before you went to prison.
- Even before I went to prison...
Years before I went to
prison, I was, I stopped
going to school. I lost
all respect for authority.
I would just... I became
a juvenile delinquent.
I was a very bad kid.
- [Mark] Tell me about your
childhood, your parents.
Did you have both parents growing up?
- I grew up with... I grew
up in a single parent home.
My dad was a truck driver.
My dad was married.
So, you know, he stayed in his marriage
and my mom, you know, raised
three, three boys by herself.
You know, she worked for the
post office, made good money
kept a roof over our heads,
clothes over our back,
and food in our stomach. She did that.
That's what my mom did.
That's one thing I got to say
that I can, my mom never,
you know, had us without.
We had everything, birthdays,
Christmases, Thanksgivings.
I had a very good life.
But growing up in an environment
a gang infested... gang
infested environment,
such as you know, where
I grew up at, you know
we got those negative influences
in the streets and you know
I became influenced, you
know, I was, you know, I was
I was a little small kid
that was very talented.
You know what I'm saying?
I knew how to play
basketball. I was funny.
I knew how to dance.
So I had a lot of friends and I, and, and
and I influenced them,
you know what I'm saying?
And through that talent
and that gift, but you know
when my behavior changed, you know
when I start getting high,
when I stopped going to school
when I stopped listening
to my mom, you know
I started adopting those, those, you know
dysfunctional belief systems,
you know, gangs, you know
I want to, I wanted to
be part of the gang.
I wanted to be, I want to fit
in, you know what I'm saying?
I wanted to be down.
And I did.
I was brave enough to do that.
I start stealing cars.
I start smoking weed.
I start selling dope. I
start picking up guns.
I started doing all those things
juvenile delinquent kids did.
And I started influencing other kids.
I really did.
I started influencing other kids.
- [Mark] They looked up to you.
- They looked up to me, they looked
up to me and my twin brother,
you know what I'm saying?
We, my mom kept us with money.
My dad, even when he came
by he kept us with money,
you know?
And it's not to take away
from, you know, any other
did the other kids that
was negative influence.
And it, you know, we, we, we, you know
I had some friends that I looked up to
you know what I'm saying?
But I had some people who really looked
up to me and they really,
and they really followed me.
They really, you know,
was allowing me to, to
to be a negative influence on them.
And, and I regret it.
No what I'm saying
I lost my life at 15
years old, I got life.
And I didn't even understand
how serious it was
at that time.
You know what I'm saying?
Because I was a hurt kid, you know
no one never really understood that.
You know what I'm saying?
I was, I had all these gifts,
I had all these talents
but I was a hurt kid.
You find what I'm saying
that, I love my mom.
You know what I'm saying?
I wanted a dad, you know what I'm saying?
Me and my twin, you know, we had a...
we loved each other, but our
relationship was dysfunctional.
You know what I'm saying?
But we love each other. We
used to fight about everything.
Everybody know that.
So it ain't no secret,
but you know what I'm saying? It was just,
I wanted to fit in. I wanted to be,
I wanted to fit in and I didn't.
And a lot of people didn't
even understand that.
I was the one that I was
really seeking the approval.
You know what I'm saying.
And that led those belief
systems that I adopted.
You know what I'm saying,
led me to get life
in prison at 15 years
old, that wasn't normal.
You didn't hear in 1996
a kid getting life in
prison, that wasn't normal.
And that's because the gang
epidemic has grew so much
to where we was destroying
our communities.
A lot of people was down.
So they was changing
laws and it was coming
down hard on gang members
and Los Angeles, Pete Wilson
and all these law makers.
And, you know, these are
the things that I found
out throughout the years, you know
when I was studying in prison
and learning about myself and learning how
to get out of prison.
But, you know, I got life
at 15 and, and it, it, it
I didn't even understand
the seriousness of it.
I was so childish.
I was so immature.
I was so naive as a kid
cause I was a child.
It was, it was, it happened so fast to me.
You know, I had my mom who
was hurt that I was even
in that situation, she
couldn't understand it either.
You know?
And you know, they, they gave me life
and I remembered the day I got life.
I walked into Tulare's court,
municipal court, adult court
holding tank, after I got found guilty,
got sentenced to life.
I told myself, I would
never get out of jail again.
I was 15 years old telling myself that
because I already, now, I
they made me understand my situation.
You understand what I'm saying?
And I went into CDC.
I went into prison, to
department of corrections
already knowing and believing
as a child that I was
never getting out of jail.
So I lost hope right then and there
you know what I'm saying?
And... I watched my mom deteriorate
but I still didn't see it.
I didn't see the pain I
caused my mother, you know
not just to myself, my mother, you know,
but most of all
I ain't even understand
what I did to my victim
the pain I caused him
because of the life I chose.
You know what I'm saying?
If I wouldn't never been a gang member
I would never did that.
I would never did life in prison.
And that's what that ultimately comes
down to for me as a man, growing
up as a man and understanding
my responsibility in my world.
And the choices I made in my life
and where I'm at right now,
just because I chose gangs.
- [Mark] What do you think
helped you make that decision?
Is it not having your
dad around all the time?
Was it, was it just the kids
in the neighborhood, friends?
- It was all the above.
It was not having my dad around.
I grew up in a single
parent home where my mom
was worked all the time.
She never was at home.
She couldn't, she couldn't control us.
I had so much free time as a child
to where as soon as I
step outside, there we go.
And my mom, you know, she spoiled us.
So she gave us a lot of freedom
and we took advantage of it,
straight up, bottom line.
I took advantage of the
freedom that my mom gave me
as a good mother and I
brought pain to her life.
I brought pain to my life
and ultimately I brought pain
to my victims life.
And I regret every bit of it.
And I had to do 22 years in prison.
I had to suffer.
I had to, I had to learn how
to become a man in prison
and I suffered. God and, and,
humanity put me through it.
It was part of, it was part of my growth.
It was part of me being held accountable
for the choices that I did.
You know, I got hurt.
I hurt people.
I've been, I've been held accountable.
I been in trouble after I
got it, got life in prison.
That's why I did 22 years.
The first time I was
eligible for parole was 2003.
I could have got out, but I
was so caught up into gangs.
I was so caught up into the
lifestyle to where I was.
I didn't have no home.
I didn't want to come
home because I was content
with spending the rest of my life in jail.
But when I lost my mother,
when I lost my mother
on her death bed, she
asked me to change my life.
But it wasn't that, she
asked my big brother
to get me out of jail.
And my big brother tried,
and let me say this.
My big brother, my big brother
tried his best to get me
out of prison, but he couldn't.
I was guilty for what I did.
I had to get myself out of prison.
I had to do...
I had to do the big major work.
I had to change my life.
I had to walk away from gangs.
That's what my whole life was about.
I had to walk away from it
in order for me to regain my life sentence
to get an opportunity to live
back out in the free world.
I had to walk away from gangs.
I had to choose gangs or my freedom.
I did that already.
I gave my life to it already.
I owe God, my victim,
my family, my community, and myself.
I deserved, I deserved
another chance I had to do it.
I had to give myself another
chance and I walked away
from it. And it took me
years to get out of prison
because I had to change my belief system.
Gangs is a lifestyle.
That's what a lot of
people don't understand.
It's a lifestyle. It's a way of thinking.
You understand what I'm saying?
And I had no choice, but
to go through the process
of changing my belief system,
adopting new belief systems.
When I start believing in God
God will start teaching me how to love.
When I started loving myself,
that's when I started loving others.
And that's when I learned
how to take responsibility
for my behavior.
That's when I learned
what empathy and remorse
and what compassion is,
I start putting myself
in my victim shoes who had to...
Who... who has to live
every day of his life
for what I did.
He has to live with that.
And I'm, and I'm sorry.
And I apologize.
And so I made a promise
that I'm gonna change my
life, even if I make mistakes
but I made a promise
that I would never again
participate in violence again in my life.
I'm gonna get out and I'm
gonna live my life productive.
I'm gonna learn how to love.
I'm gonna learn how to be kind.
I'm learn how to be respectful, you know
but it was my mother's
death that changed my life.
- [Mark] It was her death?
- And she died. She died in
prison and it was hard for me.
I never, I never, I was
back at square one again.
I lost my mother and I got life in prison.
What the hell am I living for?
What, what the hell am I living for?
And, and I'm telling you,
a lot of people know me.
So you really putting
this story on YouTube,
people is going to tell
you he's telling the truth
because everyone knows my mother
and everyone knows me and
everyone knows my twin.
And I'll tell you this right now.
It was my mother's death that
ultimately changed my life.
I owed her.
I owed her so much and the
biggest apology I could
ever give my mother was
getting out of prison.
And I'm telling you it was a journey.
And it was a process.
And I made mistakes as a man.
I made mistakes on my journey
and getting. out who doesn't?
It was a journey.
It was a mission.
And I accomplished it.
I went in front of the
board of prison terms
on my seventh term, my
sub six, and convinced him
that I'm no longer a threat to
society because I got my GED
because I got my education
because I took responsibility
for the choices and the
things I did in my life.
And I showed remorse and
empathy to my victim, his family
and my community, to people
who I hurt and destroyed.
And I did that by changing my life.
I did that by loving people in prison.
I did that by helping people in prison.
I did that by educating
myself and others in prison.
I did the footwork and
I got out of prison.
That's prison.
I did that.
Now I'm in the free world.
Look it, I'm the most happiest,
frustrated man in the world.
You understand what I'm saying?
Because I'm happy that I'm out.
I haven't been out
in the free world since
I was 15 years old.
The first thing come to my mind is I
I never gave myself a chance to live.
Here's the opportunity there I go.
What can I do?
But then on the other hand is
it's hard to live out here.
Now, reality is just sucking for me.
I'm back at square one... again.
But the... But the beautiful
thing is, is that I'm free.
But the frustrating thing is
that now I have to learn
how to be a productive
successful stable man in a free world.
Because if you don't have money
you cannot survive in the free world.
And me, I come from an era
where we don't have money.
We resort back to crime.
I can't do that.
I'm not going to do that.
It's not an option.
It's not a choice for me.
So I have to be broke.
I have to starve.
I have to sleep on the ground.
I have to sleep in a tent.
I have to check into,
into homeless shelters.
But my situation is not
because I don't have no, no
nowhere to go.
Is that since I've been in
jail, all my resources are gone.
I've been gone all my life.
My resources are limited.
You understand what I'm saying?
And I'm not out here
begging, did I have a job?
Absolutely. I had a job
but I was working for a
company that was hiring firing.
I'm only working 30 hours a week.
I need an apartment.
I need to make, I need a car.
You know, even if I need
an Uber, I need to Uber.
I need the bus.
It costs some money to survive
out here in the free world.
And it's frustrating.
And I'm not out here robbing nobody.
I'm not out here sending no dope.
I'm not doing none of that.
I'm just out here trying to survive
and learn how to live and it's hard.
And it's frustrating, but
I... I'm, I'm doing it.
And, and, and, you know, I tell...
You know, when I got out of prison,
I thought it was going to be cool for me.
I really did.
And I'm not, I'm not trying to cry.
None of that because I'm not doing that.
But it's the truth.
I miss my mother.
But at the same time, I'm like
that's the biggest apology
I gave her, was getting
out of prison.
Because I put myself in
prison and I got myself out.
And since I've been out, it's been a trial
and error and I'm out a year later.
Yeah. You know, I'm living, I'm
struggling, but I'm healthy.
And I know where I'm at in my life.
I know where I'm going and
I know where I need to be.
And that's the most important thing.
And I'm still focused.
I understand consequences.
I understand that what I
do not only just affect me
but everyone around me so
long as I continue to think
like that, I'm going to
stay mindful of my behavior.
I'm going to stay focused
because I'm a, I'm a good man.
And that's my intention.
And that's my desire.
And that's my only goal is
to just survive out here
and make an honest living.
And if I can give, become successful, Hey
that's God's plan.
But that's all.
I just want to live my life.
Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you for sharing your story.
It's an amazing story.